and this is probably a question for all
Riva what aspects in a script or an
outline would make your heart leap with
excitement what would make your heart
sink with oh my god that's going to be
toil big battles is that right or a bit
like it still down to numbers and then
looks like hundreds of stunts and and I
think also when it's there's a lot of is
effects in it as well which is quite
hard so you know you have to work with
the stunts you have to work with visual
effects you know it's so complicated to
see you miss part you need parts of
garments and you just have to work
really closely with them and it just
evolves but that's why you know you have
such a way through
I think the battles are difficult to
because they read really easily on the
page being an ethical someone so rides
and then that yeah they're not perfectly
designed doesn't read well but actually
they're intensely detailed yeah yeah
what do you think and when do you think
that's a previous series some of the
battles have become a limited production
I think when they have become Alcorn you
think of hardhome that would that have
been designed led or was that in the
script how that would learn a bit about
I think it's between probably the
writers and the director of that but I
think that I think as that was directed
by Miguel swash Nick I think he had a
lot of massaging that he did in that to
make it work the way he needed it to
work as I say on the page it doesn't
necessarily read as being as detailed as
what it was Rob I mean you find that
then much more work than they appear
yeah just just the amount of prosthetics
and dummies and costume elements and
armory elements that we have to sort of
go into so yeah but dead people dead
horses mud yes I found funny begain my
friends from set that perspective you
sort of think it's all gonna be sort of
nice cushions and drapes not just a
modern body you have a warehouse
somewhere for the dead board we've got
we've got a huge amount of dead bodies
dead horses dead bodies and this
dismember bodies and then this year
we've got into you won't be able to tell
us from one of the dead bodies maybe
there's a 1/4 on the back of one of the
text messages you walked on and there's
been a dead body wrapped up laying there
I don't think the last five months
I want faster Thursday and there's so
many because the cameras are pump
putting the tents at one so what's this
here for when I don't know and they
dragged it away it wasn't real if you
check well I know I do you have the
slides of the dragon phone audience for
I wonder where we could ask you to what
you were told to make and why you came
up with what you did but viewers will
remember this it was from Rossi so this
is the dragon stone audience chambers
thrown there she is sitting on the
throne and this was drawn by the set
decoration concept artist just simply
just in clay yeah just and jess has
drawn a lot of our furniture in hand
props over the last few seasons and this
was inspired by what about locations
called Zumaya Beach up in the Basque
Country of Spain which has this
incredible strata that sort of launches
out of the water and we didn't know a
thing about it when we first visited the
location but once we got there we
realized how special it was and the fact
that this strata almost reflected you
know the backbone of a dragon
that's when we realized that we had to
incorporate it into the space and in
terms of the size scale what what that
actually is that's a set is it that was
built in Belfast in in one of our stages
there if we built it 235 feet high so an
awful lot of it was you know the vast
majority of shots were were kept in
camera and it took up half of one of our
stages and the construction manager Tom
Martin sent down a group of plasterers
and they actually took squeezes or
imprints of this special strata the
actual rock the actual rock and then the
plasters were able to cast it back in
Belfast so that it reflected that rock
perfectly and so so what what we saw on
set was exactly the same pattern same
design as what the real location was
what is the aesthetic that we're seeing
in what were you trying to say as it
were how does this help the narrative
which I guess Dan and David were very
interested in totalitarian spaces yeah
and they wanted denier as his homecoming
to be obviously a very significant event
for that character it's something that
she's been striving towards for a long
time so it needed to be worth her
journey all of that had to amount to
something and she had to sort of
understand more about who she was I
guess by walking into that space and it
was a very uncompromising uneasy space
to be in and I think spoke a lot about
the architecture of power and what that
is and it was almost design and the
peculiar thing about it was it had been
established as an exterior many seasons
earlier episode of a map remember you
can see the macro room and you'd seen a
CGI representation of the exterior of
the castle so it was trying to weave it
all together to be a coherent Castle and
originally it was designed as a series
of caves and so what I wanted was the
building and that audience chamber to
almost be like it was standing on his
toes and sort of launching out of the
rock and
hopefully that the audience chamber
gives a bit of that feeling and so she
would enter through a cave and then come
into the chamber that then sort of rows
out the sky are you referencing any
specific buildings or architects or not
necessarily in that one I was looking at
various sort of brutalist architecture
but it wasn't as in previous seasons
drawing on one architect in particular
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]